what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
explaining every type of power that we
have seen so far in the attack on Titan
story including the many different Titan
powers Ackerman powers and a new type of
power that is advancing rapidly and is
likely going to surpass the power of the
Titans very soon I hope that compiling
all these different powers in one place
will be useful to you I am personally
fascinated by the many cool special
powers and abilities an attack on Titan
so let's get into it but before we get
started I wanted to share something with
you that I'm really excited about you
guys know I love making videos on this
channel but I often have ideas for
shorter more punchy content that just
doesn't fit on YouTube that's why I was
extremely excited when I found out about
aminos new stories feature and how
you're able to just watch new videos
about anime that I hadn't seen anywhere
else it was awesome and I love that
amino stories don't just disappear like
in other places you can watch amino
stories whenever you want so I was happy
to partner with amino to create some of
my very own stories like this 5 facts
about shanks from one piece a video that
you can only find on my amino profile
click the link in the description or
independ youtube comment or search for
amino apps to download amino find my
stories by searching anime out brawler
make sure to follow me and click the
bell to know when I'm posting new videos
just like YouTube every time you watch
my videos you'll be supporting me so if
you like my videos this is a simple free
way to keep me creating again just click
the link in the description or independ
youtube comment or just search for amino
apps to download amino and find my
stories by searching anime out bro
then just follow me and watch five facts
about shanks and just by doing that
you'll be supporting this channel and me
don't forget to tap the bell to turn on
notifications so you never miss an
upload if you enjoy the attack on titan
content on this channel you want to see
more you can leave a like to let me know
and if you're new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you'd like you can
check us out on twitter and instagram at
anime outpour for all the latest attack
on titan news and updates
finally this video will contain manga
spoilers about all the different powers
in attack on
titin so if you're not caught up to the
manga please proceed with caution you
have been warned
let's start it off with the special
powers and abilities possessed by the
pure Titans also known as the mindless
Titans the height of these Titans tends
to range between 2 and 15 meters and
they possess great physical strength as
a result of their large size they also
possess the ability to quickly
regenerate wounds and even lost body
parts so the only way to truly kill them
is of course to slice the nape of their
neck this is because the spine of the
human who became the Titan in question
is located in the nape area so if the
nape is cut the human spine will be
severed and the Titan dies these Titans
don't need to eat humans to survive but
they do need sunlight for energy and a
Titan that has not taken in any sunlight
for an extended period of time will
become immobile even though pure Titans
can pose a massive threat to humans
because of their size and because their
numbers are often overwhelming these
Titans lack intelligence and will simply
go after the first human they see as
such they can be tricked and
outmaneuvered pretty easily as long as
you don't lose your cool and start
panicking next up let's talk about the
abnormal Titans and their powers the
abnormal Titans appear to be more
intelligent than the normal Titans and
their behavior is more unpredictable
they are known to ignore the urge to go
after the first human they see in favor
of attacking more important strategic
locations such as large settlements
where more humans tend to congregate
abnormals still possess the strength
size and regeneration abilities of
normal Titans but it won't be as easy to
trick or outmaneuver an abnormal Titan
as is the case with a regular pure Titan
abnormal Titans can also possess
additional powers and abilities that
regular Titans do not such as the
ability to speak and interact with
humans to run fast at a target instead
of merely walking and to jump over
obstacles in order to get to where they
want to go now let's talk about the wall
Titans the wall Titans are giant
abnormal Titans who make up the core of
the three walls on the island of
parody's these Titans are currently in
mobile inside the walls because they
have now been exposed to the Sun for
about 100 years
however these Titans are still very much
alive
it is believed that if they are released
they would be able to flatten the entire
world because of their gigantic size and
their size is roughly comparable to the
size of the colossal titan shifter the
wall titans have the ability to harden
their bodies which allows them to make
the core of the wall more sturdy since
we've never actually seen any of the
wall titans in action all we have to go
on is second-hand information with that
in mind it is possible that the wall
titans have some additional powers and
abilities that we still don't know about
but we'll have to wait and see I want to
also briefly mention the rod reese titan
aside from the wall titans another
notable titan that is classified as
abnormal is of course Rod Reese's
gigantic 120 meter Titan along with
being the largest Titan we have ever
seen so large that it cannot even stand
upright it has to crawl along the ground
the 120 meter Titan constantly generates
steam so hard that it sets nearby trees
and shrubbery on fire as the Titan moves
because of its size this Titan is very
slow but it also possesses overwhelming
physical force and more steam power than
Victorian London a massive team effort
was required to defeat this Titan
including the use of Aaron's Titan and
powerful explosives and now let's talk
about the different Titan shifter powers
the Titan shifters are unique because
even though all Titans were once human
beings before being turned into Titans
Titans shifters are humans who can
willingly transform into Titans and then
transform back into humans at will just
like the other Titans shifters have the
ability to regenerate but not only can
Titan shifters regenerate in their Titan
form they can also regenerate wounds and
even missing limbs in their human form
once a shifter has mastered the Titan
transformation he or she is able to stay
fully conscious as a Titan and combine
the benefits of having Titan powers with
the benefits of possessing human
intelligence nevertheless as we saw with
Eren a Titan shifter may not be fully
conscious when he transforms for the
first time and it appears to take some
time before the shifter can fully master
at their transformation Titan shifters
are also able to inherit the memories of
the previous you
users of that same Titan power but the
extent to which they will be able to
access the memories depends on a few
factors if someone who is a member of
the same family as the previous holder
inherits the Titan shifter power the
memories they inherit will be more clear
than if the Titan shifter power is
passed between two strangers also the
145th king's ideology demonstrates that
having royal blood also affects to what
extent a titan shifter will inherit the
memories and beliefs of previous holders
now since the nine specific Titan
shifters have their own unique powers
and abilities I will briefly outline all
of their powers here first up we have
the attack Titan who was impressive
hand-to-hand combat capabilities and is
capable of hardening its body or parts
of its body with the help of a special
Titan serum other than that there are no
confirmed special powers that the attack
Titan possesses but there are some fan
theories and speculations the first is
the infamous berserk mode a phenomenon
that appears in the anime but not in the
manga in the anime while Eren is
fighting an e in her female Titan form
he becomes angry his titans eyes begin
to glow blue and the veins on the Titans
body light up like lava in this mode
Aaron's attacked Titan is able to move
extremely fast even running on all fours
until he catches up to Annie and tackles
her to the ground some fans believe that
this was only added in the anime in
order to make the fight more dramatic
and that this Brizard mode will not come
into play again others point to the fact
that ISA AMA has stated in the past that
he works with the anime studio and
allows the anime staff to add or correct
things that he wasn't happy about in the
manga so it is possible that the berserk
mode will come into play later and that
it has been deliberately foreshadowed in
the anime but we can't be sure for now
the other theory about this Titan
special abilities is the theory that the
attack Titan who is known for always
moving forward and fighting for freedom
has the ability to see glimpses of the
future I actually made a video on this
like two years ago but this theory stems
from Eren Krueger's ability to tell
Grisha about Armin and Myka say years
before the two of them were even born
however even if this was an example of
Titan powers
allowing the user to see into the future
we can't be certain that other Titan
shifters don't have a similar ability
especially when it comes to the still
extremely mysterious founding Titan
power next up let's talk about the
colossal Titan this Titan has the
ability to grow to the huge size of 60
metres dwarfing the other eight Titan
shifters by comparison this Titan also
has the ability to control the intensity
of its transformation this shifter can
choose to create a massive explosion
while transforming an explosion that
creates a huge mushroom cloud and
annihilates
a very large area Armin successfully
used this ability to destroy Marley's
entire naval fleet but the user of this
Titan power can also choose to create a
much less powerful splash when
transforming if the circumstances call
for him to be more subtle the colossal
Titan is able to emit massive amounts of
steam from its body and this steam will
burn everything that gets too close to
the Titans body including any potential
enemies it is worth noting that Bertolt
colossal Titan was not able to move
while emitting steam and it had to stop
emitting steam in order to be able to
continue moving the colossal Titan can
continue emitting steam as long as it
has body tissue but eventually if the
steam is released for too long the
entire body will just evaporate then we
have the armored Titans powers as the
name suggests the armored Titan has a
strong armor that covers its body and
for what we've seen so far this Titan
has impressive hand-to-hand combat
skills the armored Titans armor does
restrict its speed but the armored Titan
can ditch certain parts of its armor
such as the armor around its legs in
order to move faster next up we have the
female Titans powers the female Titan is
known for its high endurance and
mobility and this Titan also has the
ability to let out a scream that
attracts pure Titans to its location
although it seems that whenever they are
summoned the pure Titans will try to
devour the female Titan the female Titan
also has the ability to hard in certain
parts of its body which can be very
useful both offensively and defensively
the hardened skin can protect a female
Titan from attacks while also allowing
her to throw stronger more lethal
punches if she does something like
harden her
uncle's Annie's female Titan is also
able to create a crystal cocoon which
can protect the user in case they are
ever captured by the enemy
Annie was able to create this seemingly
indestructible cocoon in order to
prevent the soldiers behind the walls
from interrogating her after her Titan
was defeated by Eren and Mikasa so far
we have seen only one possible way of
breaking through this cocoon and that is
by using the JA Titans jaw to crack the
crystal now let's talk about the Beast
Titan the Beast Titan has the ability to
throw giant objects like boulders for
great distances and he can use this
ability in order to launch devastating
long-range attacks against his enemies
he can throw a single large boulder or a
bunch of smaller boulders and rocks at
the same time which results in massive
widespread damage and is very effective
against a large number of troops that
may be scattered across a wide area the
Beast Titan also has the ability to
harden parts of its body such as the
nape of its neck which is very useful
because the nape is the major weak point
for nearly all Titans
however this hardening process isn't
instant it takes some time and against a
crazy fast opponent like Levi in his
Sonic the Hedgehog mode it is possible
for the opponent to strike the Beast
Titan before the hardening can take
effect the current beast Titan also has
additional abilities but these are the
result of the fact that the current
holder Zeke has royal blood
his royal blood gives him additional
powers that previous beast Titan
shifters did not have such as the
ability to create mindless Titans using
his spinal fluid and control these pure
Titans and get them to do his bidding
interestingly Zeke is able to control
pure Titans even at night as long as
there is moonlight to energize them
because moonlight is of course just
sunlight reflecting off the surface of
the Moon then we have the cart Titan the
cart Titan does not have any special
powers or abilities when it comes to
attacking an opponent but this Titan
does have by far the best endurance and
stamina out of all the Titan shifters
and it is also very fast and
maneuverable because it moves on all
fours the cart Titan is basically the
workhorse of the Titan shifters but the
Marlin military was also able to equip
the car Titan with armor and our
hillarie there by artificially enhancing
its offensive and defensive capabilities
moving on to the jaw tighten the jaw
Titan is known for its impressive speed
and agility because its movements are
similar to that of an ape or monkey this
Titan shifters power is especially well
suited for terrain like forests where it
can grab on to many different objects
like trees which allows it to move
quickly and with great versatility the
jaw Titan also has extremely powerful
claws and of course an extremely
powerful jaw its claws and jaw can break
through even hardened Titan armor and as
we learned during the fight against the
warhammer tighten the jaw Titan can even
crack the hardened crystal cocoons like
the one in which a knee is currently
sealed next up is the Warhammer Titan
this Titan has the unique ability to
create weapons using the same powerful
material that Titans used to harden
their bodies and the Warhammer Titan can
create everything from Spears and spikes
to bows and arrows allowing it to launch
effective short-range and long-range
attacks in addition the Warhammer Titan
is the only Titan who can keep its users
separate from the body of the Titan
during the battle against the Warhammer
Titan in male the Titan user at the time
willy Tiber sister was able to seal
herself inside the same type of crystal
cocoon that Annie is currently sealed in
and as long as this cocoon is connected
to the Titans body through a cable of
flesh the Warhammer Titan can function
this means that the user can protect
himself or herself inside a cocoon while
using the Titan and so trying to attack
the Warhammer Titans nape is completely
useless if the connection between the
cocoon and the user is severed the user
can just create another Titan body
without ever leaving the cocoon which
again is a huge deal because it allows
the user to remain relatively safe while
the battle rages on the outside however
the JA Titans jaw is able to break
through this crystal cocoon and Eren
uses the JA Titans jaw for that very
purpose he forces the jaw Titan to break
through the cocoon against his will and
then proceeds to eat willy Tiber sister
thereby inheriting the Warhammer
it's power and finally we have the
founding Titan the true power of this
Titan can only be harnessed with the use
of royal blood
and for the vast majority of its history
this shifter was passed on through the
different generations of the royal Fritz
family the founding Titan has some
incredibly opie abilities including the
ability to manipulate and erase the
memories of all the subjects of aamir
that is to say all ldiots
the founding Titan can also be used to
transform LD ins into pure and abnormal
Titans like we saw with the giant wall
Titans that were used to form the core
of the three walls on top of creating
Titans the founding time can also
control these Titans and order them to
do his or her bidding this is similar to
Zeke's current abilities due to his own
royal ancestry but we can assume that
the founding Titans ability to create
and control Titans is many levels beyond
anything he can do in addition rumor has
it that the founding Titan is able to
not only manipulate the memories of LD
ends but also their entire biological
composition for instance there are
stories that the founding Titan can make
all LD ins immune to a specific disease
by changing their biological composition
Zeke also believes that this power can
be used to sterilize all ldiots thereby
ensuring the extinction of the entire
nation within just one generation
however it is important to note that
whenever the founding titan power is
inherited by a member of the royal
family they also inherit the 145th
king's ideology they suddenly become
pacifists and they are completely
unwilling to interfere in the affairs of
the world beyond the walls even in the
face of the discrimination that LD ins
continue to face on the continent now
let's talk about Ackerman powers the
Ackerman's are a minority bloodline on
the island of paradise which means that
they were not affected by the 145th
king's memory manipulation since this
power only works on ldiots at first all
we know about the Ackerman's is that
they are a minority that once guarded
the royal family but was then persecuted
because of their refusal to follow the
145th king's ideology and we also know
that some members of the Ackermann clan
are extremely powerful fighters
including of course Mikasa Levi and Ken
but in Chapter 93 of the manga we
learned that the Ackerman's are a
byproduct of titan science even though
they cannot turn into titans the
Ackermann bloodline was somehow
manipulated so that they can manifest
the power of the titans in human form
this was likely done in order to turn
the Ackerman's into an elite fighting
force that serves the LD and royal
family this mysterious power of the
Ackerman's does not manifest at birth
instead it has to be awakened in a
moment of danger an Ackerman's mind
suddenly becomes clear of all
distraction and they know exactly what
to do after that the Ackermann in
question becomes an incredibly powerful
fighter whose skills are far beyond the
skills of an average human and that is
quite clear when we look at someone like
Levi and everything he has been able to
accomplish on the battlefield we later
learned at once an acraman awakens they
instantly gained the combat experience
of every other Ackerman before them
through the same mysterious paths that
allow Titan shifters to inherit the
memories of previous Titan shifters in
chapter 112 we get more information
about how exactly Ackerman powers work
but we have to take this information
with a grain of salt because the
information may not be completely
accurate
apparently in order for an achromatic
our to activate and in order for them to
awaken they need two things they need a
person to protect and they must obey an
order from that person in the face of
imminent death so in the case of Mikasa
when her parents were killed and Aaron
was about to be killed by one of the
murderers after risking his life to save
her
he had told Mikasa to fight in this
instant mikasa ackerman powers awakened
she suddenly knew exactly what to do and
she killed the murderer without
hesitation
Eren claims that once an achromatic
wakens they are compelled to serve the
person who gave them the order in the
moment of their awakening so for
instance Eren ordering Mikasa to fight
and the acraman in question will have
severe consequences such as headaches if
they ever tried to fight the urge to
save the person in question
Eren uses this information to explain -
Mika said that she doesn't really love
him or care about him she is merely
following her notch
Rolle acraman instincts to serve him
because he is the reason that she
awakened so he is the person that she is
compelled to protect however Armand
doesn't believe this he thinks that
Aaron is lying about at least some of
this because he wants to distance
himself from Eren and Mikasa probably
because the relationship he currently
has with Zeke would put the two of them
in danger we'll have to wait and see but
personally I agree with Armin Mika says
feelings for Aaron go way beyond just
loyalty they have a clear emotional
dimension and as a matter of fact in the
past Mikasa has actually stood up to
Eren she even physically hit him in
season one of the anime without
suffering any visible consequences for
that action which seems to contradict a
claim that she is physically compelled
to always protect him and finally we
have a power that is quickly surpassing
even the power of the Titans and it is
threatening to render the Titan powers
useless in battle and this power is of
course modern technology as modern
technology advances rapidly on the
continent and military weapons including
guns and artillery are becoming stronger
and more efficient it seems clear that
soon modern weapons will surpass the
power of titans there are already modern
weapons in existence that can pierce the
armored Titans armor and if technology
continues to advance within a matter of
only a few years the Titans may be an
insignificant factor on the battlefield
think about it if your artillery is
strong enough to take down Titans before
they even get close to you and if you're
able to use airships or even airplanes
to bomb the island of paradise without
ever having to go through the walls in
the first place then Titans will no
longer pose a threat to you on the
battlefield and that is exactly what
appears to be happening and a few
intelligent LD ins like Peake and Zeke
have already picked up on this a while
ago once Titan Power has become
irrelevant and LD ins are no longer
needed to service members of Marlies
military it is quite possible that
Marlay and the rest of the world will
decide to get rid of all the audience
all together and that is the current
threat that is facing LD ins on a global
scale
well that and Zeke's crazy insane plan
right now the story of attack on Titan
is as interesting as it's ever been and
if you are still not caught up to the
manga I strongly suggest you get caught
up as soon as possible
it's honestly amazing anyway let me know
what you guys think which is your
favorite type of power in attack on
Titan and do you think that modern
technology is about to make all Titan
powers irrelevant and if so what would
that mean for the future of ldiots let
me know down in the comments if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more you can leave a like to let me know
and if you're new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell you can also follow us
on twitter and instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest attack on titan news
and updates a huge thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for supporting
our work i want to give a special thank
you to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson and Kings
eldress and another huge thank you to
our the one tier patrons the ones who
stand above all other clans including
ace Ingrid ah
Maddy Mack and makoto-kun and at the
very pinnacle of interdimensional
greatness the tier reserved only for
legends a massive thank you to regan
harrison a disciple of lords we go
himself if you guys feel that our
content provides value for you and you
want to support more be sure to check
out our patreon link in the description
even donating a single dollar will give
you access to our anime outpour patron
exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching I really appreciate
it and until next time see us space
cowboys
[Music]